se necesitaron a más de 75 años para
encontrar miles de páginas manuscritas
firmadas por Luis
este es el manuscrito de La Leyenda del
Rey
abandonado por el autor en la liberación
de 1944 este manuscrito reapareció en
2020 junto con otras a más de 5.300
páginas robadas al novelista tras una
investigación por robo la policía las
devolvió a sus dos propietarios elegimos
nos dieron un volumen considerable
y ahí la comisaría denantedas había una
verdadera emoción compartida Por la
policía
ellos mismos se dieron cuenta de que
desde el punto de vista cultural se
trataba de documentos considerables
pertenecen al patrimonio cultural
francés por supuesto la investigación
comenzó aquí en la oc la oficina central
de lucha contra el tráfico de bienes
culturales creada en 1975
interviene para proteger a cualquier
objeto de valor artístico histórico o
arqueológico perteneciente al patrimonio
cultural de un país
Esta es la sala donde se guardan todos
los bienes culturales que se incautan en
el curso de un procedimiento judicial
bajo el mando del Coronel vpsie una
treintena de policías y gendarmanes se
ocupan de casos complejos de robo
manipulación de bienes robados pillaje y
blanqueo de capitales en los que están
implicadas redes delictivas
internacionales
hay varios tipos de compradores tenemos
coleccionistas a los que les gustan los
objetos bellos
tenemos compradores especulativos porque
en tiempos de crisis los objetos de arte
son un refugio seguro
luego tenemos gente que busca blanquear
activos delictivos
daño unos 100.000 robos de bienes
culturales se trata de un delito
castigado con penas de 7 a 10 años de
cárcel esta base de datos es una de las
herramientas utilizadas por los
investigadores para rastrear las rutas
de tráfico
obtenemos las fotos las registramos en
la base de datos podemos compartirlas
con Interpol
y esto nos permite hacer un seguimiento
a lo largo de varios años
y comprobar que si el objeto reaparece
en una sala de subastas o en algún sitio
podemos verificar en qué condiciones fue
Hurtado
en los últimos años ha aumentado el
tráfico sobre todo en la red lo que
facilita la circulación de artículos de
origen fraudulento según la UNESCO el
comercio ilícito de bienes culturales
representa cada año cerca de Diez mil
millones de dólares se trata del Tercer
comercio mundial después del de drogas y
armas
las mercancías procedentes de zonas en
conflicto son objeto de escrutinio
especial como las procedentes del medio
oriente y ahora de Ucrania donde miles
de objetivos han sido saqueados por los
rusos a Según dice kievón
un robo un saqueo de un país ya no
permite que la comunidad que vive en ese
país esté representada simbólicamente en
ese objeto
Así que el valor es mucho más que
financiero
Acabamos de terminar un curso de
formación en Polonia con los estados que
tienen frontera con Ucrania
para ver cómo concienciar a las aduanas
para evitar que estas mercancías salgan
del país
garantizar la autenticidad y la
procedencia dos problemáticas
fundamentales en el centro de un
escándalo sin precedentes en el mundo
del arte
recientemente el museo Metropolitano de
arte de Nueva York y el look de abu
dhabi adquirieron piezas de procedencia
ilegal basándose en certificados falsos
un asunto espinoso que la ocbc sigue
intentando resolver
en respuesta el Ministerio de cultura
francés presentó unas 40 propuestas para
asegurar el mercado del arte Pero según
el presidente del sindicato nacional de
anticuarios Francia ya dispone de uno de
los arsenales legislativos más
restrictivos en este ámbito
les mostraré lo que es un libro de
policía
que todo profesional anticuario y
galerista debe tener listo puedes ver el
nombre del vendedor
la fecha en que la galería compró cada
obra
una descripción detallada y el precio de
adquisición
no llevar este registro se castiga con
seis meses de cárcel y una multa de
30.000 euros Matías arellana aboga por
transparencia y la confianza teme que
las nuevas restricciones ralenticen el
mercado francés En beneficio de la
competencia China y estadounidense y fue
al abuelo necesitamos tanto rigor como
planteamientos serios para Los
profesionales y tenemos que estar
atentos y no ser ingenuos
pero al mismo tiempo el mercado debe ser
fluido y no debemos ahogar el mercado
francés que actualmente crece con
rapidez
aumentar una reglamentación demasiado
burocrática para las pequeñas
estructuras destruiría el mercado y
sería contraproducente
una pérdida de activos una pérdida de
transacciones una pérdida para todos
desde el brexit Francia se ha convertido
en el primer mercado del arte de la
Unión Europea impulsado por las subastas
y las nft que aportaron al país es casi
mil millones de euros el año pasado